kevin schwarze wurde 21 jahre alt
erschossen von einem antisemitischen
rechts- terrorist kevin bei fan des
halleschen fc ein jahr später zieht es
die fans wieder ins stadion und verein
und fern betreuer betonen dass sie schon
lange klare kante zeigen gegen rechts
nicht erst seit dem anschlag vor meiner
zeit im fanprojekt
damals schon nach israel fahren hat dort
bildungs also hat bildungsreisen für die
fans angeboten um sich mit dem thema
auseinanderzusetzen
ich glaube dass das immer das
bewusstsein dafür ist immer da beim
nächsten heimspiel soll des
antisemitischen terrors gedacht werden
der vor einem jahr hallenser juden galt
aber den fußballfan kevin traf eine
offizielle schweigeminute nicht allen
ist das wichtig ist an schlaf war für
mich im moment ja und das hat wird es
mit fußball studio herz ist im stadion
trauer turnier um den ansprachen also
ist natürlich traurig was da abging hat
gehört das zusammen
eigentlich nicht weil fußball ein
anschlag dass es kein thema
hfc fan kevin schwarze wurde in diesem
döner-imbiss erschossen
das mädchen hatte am 9 oktober 2019
dienst vor einem jahr schilderte
frontal21 wie er die tat erlebt hat ist
dann bin ich hingegangen habe ich
gesehen ist breit ist leben gekommen
ein jahr später treffen wir ihn wieder
er hat den imbiss von seinem früheren
chef übernommen doch der laden steht vor
dem aus denn wer mag schon an einem
tatort essen is matt hat sich an den
hallenser oberbürgermeister gewandt
unterstützt von einer professionellen
opfer beraterin
[Musik]
ein direkt betroffener des anschlags
fragt der bürgermeister nimmt ihn beim
wort und fragt ich möchte gerne treffen
und er sagte nicht persönlich nicht und
trotzdem sind wir in gedanken wenn man
eine bürgermeister sein soll dann muss
man solche sachen auch mit rechnungen
wie man mit den menschen umgehen und er
wäre es irgendwie das mindeste gewesen
zu sagen als stadt egal wie wir
versuchen gemeinsam dieses ziel zu
verfolgen
das was passiert es ist dass die
mitarbeiterin gesagt haben herr tägigen
sie können ein hartz4 antrag stellen
und das ist mit andern der
oberbürgermeister hatte das persönliche
gespräch abgesagt wir fragen ihn
vergangene woche
warum der gewerbetreibende stand mit
einer vielzahl von terminen mit uns in
verbindung
es ging ja auch darum seine
geschäftlichen interessen auch stärker
wieder ins licht zu rücken und ihnen
auch hier zu stärken das haben wir mit
unseren mitarbeitern getan hinlänglich
und von daher kann ich das nicht mehr
schützen halle am 9 oktober 2009 10
schwer bewaffnet versucht ein angreifer
die synagoge am höchsten jüdischen
feiertag zu stürmen
52 menschen sind drin nur die tür rede
tiere leben zwei passanten erschießt der
wahllos bis heute gibt es streit
zwischen der jüdischen gemeinde und dem
land sachsen-anhalt wer für mehr
sicherheit sorgt das land hat geld
angeboten damit die gemeinde sich selber
kümmert nach unserer verfassung
unabhängig davon ob das geld ausreichend
ist oder nicht die zuständigkeit muss
auf jeden fall beim land bleiben
die hdmi dass das land gibt das geld der
jüdischen gemeinschaft und die jüdische
gemeinschaft dann sehr bürokratisch
müsste dieses prozedere durchführen
der beklagte innenminister von
sachsen-anhalt am vergangenen freitag
die vielen polizei stunden die für die
sicherung jüdischer einrichtungen
notwendig seien
ein fauxpas den holger stahlknecht heute
klarstellen muss und für mich ist der
schutz jüdischen lebens unverhandelbar
punkt in der bin ich missverstanden
worden und das hat mich zutiefst
erschüttert und betroffen
[Musik]
halle ist nicht nur schauplatz eines
antisemitischen attentat
bis heute ist der marktplatz der stadt
allwöchentlich aufmarsch ort für einen
landesweit bekannten rechtsextremisten
das mädchen das hat er erfahrung dem
eingeschlossen seien ihr eine corona
demo ende mai sorgt in ganz deutschland
für entsetzen neonazis wenn liebig im
anne frank t shirt judensterne gegen
pandemie maßnahmen die er aus halle in
ganz deutschland vertreibt die polizei
als versammlungsbehörde sieht sich
außerstande gegen diese verharmlosung
des holocaust einzuschreiten
für viele einzelhändler ist dass gerade
nach dem anschlag unerträglich er hat
seiner fangemeinde gehen 10 15 mann mehr
sind es ja nicht alle anderen verlassen
mehr wege fluchtartig den platz wenn
eher lieblich hier ist ein auto in
seinem mikrofon und ein lautsprecher
ausbaut
die hat uns das nicht um das soll sich
nun ändern
vergangene woche im stadtrat der
oberbürgermeister will erreichen dass
künftig die stadthalle und nicht die
polizei für die anmeldung von
versammlungen zuständig ist
[Musik]
nach hause das auf dem halleschen
marktplatz regelmäßig auch an sensiblen
tagen wohnen innehalten angebrachter
wäre ein rechtsextremer den marktplatz
zusammen brüllt und da ist es wichtig
als demokratische gesellschaften zeichen
zu setzen und klar zu machen dass wir
das nicht akzeptieren
außer der afg sind sich darin alle einig
doch das prozedere kann dauern so dass
auch am gedenktag neonazi liebig wieder
auf dem marktplatz stehen könnte
vergangenen samstag zum tag der
deutschen einheit wollen migrantinnen
und migranten mit gebürtig deutschen ins
gespräch kommen
fast genau ein jahr nachdem der hass auf
angeblich fremde sich hier bahn brach
geht es ihnen darum zu zeigen dass auch
sie alender unterländerinnen sind
noch mehr dagegen zu kämpfen rassismus
und für demokratie für die demokratische
werte mein wille ist größer geworden und
ich habe noch mehr kraft bekommen
ich werde nicht weggehen ich bin in
halles zu hause
doch viele sind nicht gekommen und manch
einer ist ein jahr danach nicht ganz
glücklich damit wie sich die beziehungen
in der stadt entwickelt haben
ich bin eigentlich bisschen betroffen
darüber dass jüdische gemeinde wenig
sich in der stadt zeigt bis nach dem
anschlag auch nicht ein bisschen mehr
zusammengerückt
das habe ich eben gedacht war ja gerade
von ihrer ländern viel viel anteilnahme
gezeigt worden ist das ist genau mein
problem
doch viele juden leben in halle noch
immer mit der angst
so findet ihr höchster feiertag jom
kippur in der vergangenen woche unter
enormen sicherheitsmaßnahmen statt wie
der anschlag von hamburg vor wenigen
tagen erneut zeigt ist es in deutschland
ein großes risiko seinen jüdischen
glauben öffentlich zu zeigen
man muss nicht unbedingt erwarten dass
immer wieder hunderte leute synagoge
kommen sondern dass wirklich alle
solidarisch bleiben und dass diese hass
was in der gesellschaft existiert also
das potenzial wird abgebaut diese
menschen die zu uns gekommen sind
die sind auch geimpft nach meiner
auffassung dass dieses potenzial beträgt
nach dem anschlag war die solidarität in
der halle überwältigen
ein jahr danach bringt die stadt mit
sich um hass um haltung und um heimat
damit eben dass sie zum schauplatz wurde
eines antisemitischen verbrechens dass
keiner der es überlebt hat jemals
vergessen wird